pour quelques privilégiés en ce moment
même en avant première un film un film
abondamment annoncé déjà et qui aura
sans doute un très large accueil
populaire à la fiche est dit marcel
claude et beaucoup d'autres claude
lelouch a consacré sa dernière oeuvre à
l'évocation d'un couple historique dans
l'eau dans nos mémoires edith piaf et
marcel cerdan le fils de marcel joue le
rôle de son père
evelyne bouix celui de piaf et charles
aznavour joue le rôle de charles
aznavour comme il vient de l'expliquer
alors qu'il chante en ce moment à new
york
edith et marcel vu par franz och
la fille de noir ébène au coin de la rue
là bas
elle a une clientèle qui lui rend
glissons bas
loi
rien
edith et marcel une histoire d'amour
comme un conte de fées qui finirait mal
à ma droite marcel cerdan qui a battu
tony d'sel dans un combat historique et
apporter le championnat du monde à la
france
à ma gauche la première vedette varient
du tout y est la seule chanteuse
française à avoir conquis l'amérique et
le choeur du champion dans le film de
claude lelouch piaf c'était bimbo x qui
chante avec la vraie voix d'edith srd
ans est un débutant à l'écran le petit
garçon cette image marcel fils de max m
un petit peu embêté au départ je voulais
pas le faire et vous connaissez le
charme de lelouch quand il veut quelque
chose il a un tel charme et fini par
l'avoir
il avait tellement d'enthousiasmé ils
avaient tellement envie de faire ce film
c'est tellement une oeuvre d'amour pour
lui que moi même je proposais bon bah
écoute ça fait rien je vais mais je vais
me teindre les cheveux on va voir ce que
ça donne
qui était ce un temps fort se mettait à
personnages adorables et gentille et
tendre et doux qui découvrait mille
choses qui découvrait la musique qui
découvrait la littérature qui découvre
un monde qui n'était pas le sien qui
s'ouvre est finalement un tel était
intellectuellement il s'ouvre est
merveilleusement c'était un homme tp
j'avais toutes les possibilités vous qui
était un culte
la naine et pia ce qu'était elle pourra
nager et qu'est ce qu'il était pour elle
qu'est-ce qu'on était pour pierre canton
n'était pas sans son compagnon de vie on
était un petit peu tout
j'étais l'auteur par le compositeur
j'écris mais surtout les paroles le
confident non piaf ne vais pas de
confident disons le complice plutôt que
le confident le compagnon de beuverie
pour avoir peur des mots vous le dire
mais mais bien ici on avait on buvait du
vin rouge dans certains pays de la bière
dans d'autres met aux états unis on
buvait du champagne et surtout une seule
marque blanche
or on est en panne cool
les fermiers
dans le bleu
mon fils est mort
oh
quoi au fait